cooking a burger at Chili's used to look
like this five minutes of Smashing
flipping and waiting
now it looks like this
the Patty grilling on both sides at the
same time
it takes just two minutes and five
seconds to go from order to plate and
Chili's needs those three minutes to
translate to bigger sales it's just one
of the many changes that might seem
unnecessary even pointless but they
could save the company at least six and
a half million dollars every year
here's how Chili's is pivoting its
kitchens to focus on speed and why it
thinks fixing inefficiencies will bring
back customers
they were once a real category leader in
casual dining that space now is very
crowded there's a lot of other kind of
casual dining chains out there so the
chain tried to attract younger customers
by filling the menu with more options
but a big menu is really hard to manage
you have to keep a lot of ingredients in
your kitchens you have to train your
workers so the restaurant reduced the
menu by almost 20 percent going from 92
items to 73 the company says it saved
Millions by having fewer ingredients
what are the menu items that are either
duplicate on the menu or don't really
sell and create a lot of prep steps for
the kitchen and so we've eliminated a
lot of those take this Fried Chicken for
example there used to be two types of
chicken crispers on the menu and put
individually coat and Fry every chicken
piece to order
so to make the station more efficient
the restaurant got rid of tempura
breaded chicken now the chicken can be
tossed in just one type of breading in
bulk up to 30 pieces at a time the
company says that saves 10 percent of
workers time that is a huge amount of
not just Time Savings but more
importantly it allows you to sell a
whole lot more Crispers during a very
tight window of time during service and
the restaurant hopes
service means
means diners but not everyone is happy
about the menu changes the original
chicken crispers have been my order for
my entire life 26 years of tradition and
you just take it away
like it means nothing there is a certain
nostalgia for the food that's been on
their menu you know losing a favorite
menu item really might be devastating
and they might not want to go back the
company acknowledges that cutting down
the menu could drive away some customers
but it says it's worth the risk we're
actually selling more Crispers now with
one breading than we did with two
breading because they're coming out more
consistent and hotter and fresher and
it's not
not kitchen Time by getting rid of tasks
entirely Chili's says workers used to
spend at least an hour every day
counting and bagging this shrimp to be
used throughout service in theory it
could be a whole lot faster to be able
to grab that bag the reality is it's not
any faster and that's just essentially
wasting time during prep that could be
spent on other things to make the food
even better so now workers just pack the
shrimp after prep by eyeballing it the
only portion of shrimp when they need to
cook it according to the company that
shrimp bagging tour was costing it six
million dollars annually across its 1
100 restaurants and though the chain
says it's saving time and money with
fewer tasks it's not cutting jobs as a
result they're not actually cutting the
money from their budget that is some of
the money they're using to reinvest into
you know bringing on more staff hours to
helping you know with the service level
but that is Meaningful I mean that is
millions of dollars and it's not just
the shrimp bagging getting the ax the
company has also stopped serving fry
eyes and baskets it says workers were
washing 40 million times a year that's
an estimated 430 thousand dollars in
annual savings from not buying them
according to the company
Chili's is also buying smaller pickle
jars
the company says the old ones were a
pain to open and Portion out now it's as
easy as unscrewing the top the company
says that alone will save it half a
million dollars annually the tasks and
changes might appear small but that does
add up when you you're talking over a
thousand restaurants all over the
country Beyond trimming menus and chores
the company is looking to make kitchens
faster overall it's invested in testing
new equipment like that Grill from
earlier that can sell for around thirty
eight thousand dollars workers don't
have to worry about watching the food
while it cooks and more food can be
prepared with less time this is
expensive it's not cheap to get these
new grills or these ovens this is a
really big investment but it seems that
Chili's is taking this back because they
do think it will pay off that section of
the kitchen has gone from being the
hardest part of the kitchen to run to
actually being the easiest part of the
kitchen but the company says that
installing the equipment will be slow
the new equipment is in just 67 of the
Chain's more than one thousand
restaurants it's going to take years to
roll out between both building equipment
you know assessing our restaurants on
where to install the equipment and
getting the equipment installed the
company says that focusing on a on
efficiency also makes workers jobs
easier as the chain grapples with labor
shortages and inflation what we're
finding is ticket times are going down
food scores are going up but most
importantly team members are finding it
really easy to serve the guests very
quickly and that's exciting because we
know if we can improve speed of service
that's going to lead to sales growth
early profits
Excel down part
ly pandemic though it has been improving
and Chili's has been lagging in sales
compared to some of its Rivals like
Applebee's and Texas Roadhouse other
competitors are looking to improve
kitchen efficiency and customer value
too some of these vintage Legacy casual
dining chains real realize they have to
change you know they have to make sure
they're delivering for guests in a way
that keeps them coming and
one of the most important part of that
is to have good service and for Chili's
good service hinges on workers being
able to do their jobs well
as long as we stay focused on those
things we're going to continue to see
both improvements and metrics with
customers as well as sustainable sales
growth
[Music]